there is a just Blockbuster bombshell
new story that we must talk about and I
want to kind of set this up for you by
telling you what this is not about we
have Trump Russia going on with a
special prosecutor Robert Muller put
that aside for now we have this abortive
attempted confirmation of Donald Trump's
Supreme Court pick Brett Kavanaugh an
alleged serial sex assault er this is
not that story we have which we'll talk
about a little bit later on in the
program this not really new trade deal
called the u.s. MCA put that aside for
now put basically every scandal and
every failed promise aside that we have
seen from and by the Trump
administration for now because we have
something totally new that's going on
this is a new state tax investigation
that has started as a result of massive
massive allegations of fraud against
Donald Trump and his family in a just
extraordinarily detailed and thoroughly
researched New York Times special
investigation so here's what's going on
New York Times yesterday has published a
to call it lengthy as an understatement
to call it extensive as an
understatement
investigation which exposes that Trump
and his family have committed quote
instances of outright fraud that is a
direct phrase from the investigation
meant to transfer millions upon millions
of dollars from Trump's father Fred
Trump to his kids without paying the
taxes that one is supposed to pay in
addition to just the claims made by the
New York Times New York state tax
officials have said we are now looking
into this there is a confirmed state tax
state-level tax investigation into what
the allegations are from the New York
Times yet another one of Donald Trump's
lawyers this is one I hadn't previously
heard of his name is Charles harder
apparently that's his real name
he obviously deny
that Donald Trump has done anything
wrong has committed any fraud no
wrongdoing whatsoever
according to councilor harder the
mechanisms used here according to the
investigation to move this money around
in a way that it would not be subject to
the taxes that would normally be
prescribed by law include number one
improper tax deductions number two the
straight-up undervaluation of real
estate holdings by hundreds of millions
of dollars that what what that quite
simply means is that if you have a
building worth you know twenty million
dollars just the numbers don't really
matter when you transfer that you
straight up claim that the value of that
building is much smaller which reduces
the transfer tax liability and other
taxes that may be associated depending
on whether those property transfers are
happening while the owner is alive or
through their estate once they have
passed away the New York Times also
writes because this is as soon as I read
this the scope and size of this
investigation is so significant that any
realistically credible investigative
entity would absolutely be in touch with
the people who are the subjects of the
story in this case Donald Trump and his
family to get comment from them and
indeed they they have been they've
explained that for weeks as they've been
working on this story they tried to get
statements from Trump about this they
told him they are working on this
another nothing other than this brief
statement in which Charles harder says
yeah this was Trump's family but Trump
didn't actually do anything it has
nothing to do with Trump period it is
important to point out and this is where
we get to you know we have at least two
justice systems and we also have
probably probably more than that in some
way remember actor Wesley Snipes actor
Wesley Snipes was sentenced to three
years in prison because of tax charges
were a mere fraction of what is alleged
here against Donald Trump and his family
that's what I was thinking as I read
through this piece and read through the
allegations that are made here and the
other thing that went through my mind is
if the New York Times was able to figure
out this much stuff and in such detail
about Donald Trump's family's financial
dealings and potential criminality
Muller must know way more than any of us
are accounting for right and that is
something that importantly signals that
the claims that Trump was laundering
Russian money those claims are even more
credible because it appears as though
his entire family has been doing exactly
those types of financial manipulations
through real estate for a decade upon
decade think about that for a moment if
you read Trump's been laundering money
for Russians for years might be true
might be circumstantially supported by
things we know about Donald Trump and
what he and his sons have said but we
now have specific allegations from the
New York Times extraordinarily well
researched allegations that the Trump
family has made it not a habit but a
sort of way of life to use real estate
to move money around in ways that are
evading what the law is surrounding that
money it is significantly more
believable it's almost obvious that of
course Trump was doing money laundering
for the Russians through real estate he
learned how to use real estate to move
money around discreetly or or
surreptitiously from his own father
if this investigation is to be believed
so in the last 24 hours consider what
we've learned in the last 24 - I guess
36 hours we've learned that Brett
Kavanaugh and we'll talk about this
momentarily try to fix his alibi before
Debora Ramirez allit read Debora
Ramirez's allegations were made public
via The New Yorker article and
potentially tampered with witnesses we
learned that Donald Trump tried to get
stormy dan
silenced in advance of that story going
public and now we are learning more and
more about the really undeniable reality
as we've suspected for a long time that
Donald Trump's wealth likely came not
just from that small loan of a million
dollars from his dad but also from
massive criminal level tax fraud which
we are only starting to learn about one
other just little note it's very
interesting to me that the way that this
was supposedly being done according to
the New York Times it involves sort of
more nuanced and sophisticated
accounting and tax stuff and then it
also involves just basic lying about how
billed how much buildings are worth
which is sort of exactly emblematic of
how Donald Trump does things he will lie
and deceive in ways that are more
sophisticated and then he'll straight-up
lie to your face which is exactly what
you're doing when you say my 50 million
dollar building now that this isn't a
good building this thing's only worth 2
million dollars we will absolutely be
following this and again there is now a
new investigation by the New York State
tax department and we'll see what they
ultimately come up with